la première fois que j'ai vu des centaines de salles, c'était en
juillet 1919, rien n'aurait pu me
préparer au sortilège qu'il a jeté quand j'ai revu la
maison 30 ans plus tard, je pouvais à
peine comprendre le changement de l'
endroit pourquoi ne me dites-vous pas ce qui se passe
, vous le feriez  't me croire un autre
c'est dr.  Faraday
j'ai déjà défini le patient peu
sous le temps
c'est
Warshaw tristement nerveux
[Musique]
il y a longtemps était un enfant ici qu'est-ce
qu'il fait ici Susan est morte avant ma
naissance
il y a quelque chose de mal dans cette maison
ne tirons pas sur Betty qu'est-ce que tu fais
ici vous avez raison pour moi mademoiselle je ne l'ai pas
fait c'était mal orthographié que le mal s'essayant l'a
fait ce qui est pour le bruit
votre esprit joue des tours
Susan est un souvenir tout peut
s'expliquer à quel point IVA innocent cette illusion
semblait presque contagieuse
quelqu'un joue à des jeux  il y a
généralement des femmes que les trucs impitoyables
il y a quelque chose dans cette maison qui
nous aide tu n'as pas ta place ici
ouais
toi